[Music]
let me take you all the way back to 2003
that year the folks from NCIS popped up
on jag so it was pretty cool when the
Jag stars David James Elliott and
Catherine Bell joined NCIS LA last
season and guess what they are back for
the new season and we have your first
look back what's the plan letting fate
decide
but had been but 14 years so it was like
a comfortable old shoe eventually it
made the first scene I was oh it back
the big thing fans are looking out for
hookups between David and Kathryn this
is a difficult situation David James
Elliot and Kathryn may have been
separated for quite some time a lot of
the fans up that off a million know that
they had a little fling going I tell you
they were lost it's not to lose you
promise yeah no matter what happens you
want me et was on the set of jag back in
2001 David and Kathryn played military
lawyers but it's their sexual tension
that kept viewers hooked for nine
seasons you know it's like we're really
comfortable with each other so it it it
doesn't feel weird or awkward at all
it's really it's totally professional
and it's just we're very close that's
nice
now bill guest star to help LL Cool J
and Chris O'Donnell track down spies we
have information regarding missile
attack those guys couldn't have been
more welcoming and they were fun to play
with and really every day was just a joy
so now the question is does this jag
reunion mean there could be a spin-off
of a spin-off and jag could come back
we're talking about it right now
season 11 of NCIS la kicks off September
29th on CBS
[Music]